PRIYANKA VERGADIA: How do I
say Hello, World in Japanese?
SPEAKER 1: [JAPANESE]
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: And
what about in Spanish?
SPEAKER 2: [SPANISH]
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Well, stay with me
as we explore the Translation
API to make our apps global.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to "AI
Adventures," where
we explore the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
I'm Priyanka Vergadia,
and today, we're
talking about Translation API.
Have you ever typed "how
do I say tomatoes in Hindi"
in your Google Search?
I bet you have.
Well, maybe not exactly that,
but something similar, right?
Then you have used Google's
translation models.
But what if you could use the
power of this translation model
to translate your
websites and apps, making
them instantly usable across
the world in multiple languages?
Well, that's where
Translation API comes in.
It is a high-quality
pre-change translation model
that can automatically identify
more than 100 languages
and translate them.
You can easily integrate
your website or apps
with it using the REST API.
Let's see how.
First, enable the Translation
API in your project
and create a service
account for authentication.
Make sure you provide the
Cloud Translation API editor
role to your service account
and generate a JSON key.
This will be used to
authenticate our call.
I love Cloud Shells, so here,
I'm using curl from Cloud Shell
to call the Translation API.
But you can use the
language of your choice.
We authenticate
the service using
the key we downloaded earlier.
Now, let's say we want to
translate "the weather is
amazing today" into Hindi.
Here, we are setting
both source and target,
but the source is
optional, since the API can
autodetect the source language.
We pass this requester JSON file
as a payload with our HTTP post
request to the Translation API.
And we get the
translation, [HINDI]..
This is great.
Let's try another example now.
"Google Cloud is an
amazing technology."
Even though this is technically
a correct translation,
it still feels weird.
This is because Google
Cloud is a proper noun,
and should not be translated.
In such cases, where you have
product names, company names,
and other proper nouns,
you would like more control
over how these specific
words are translated.
That's where Translation
API's Advanced Glossary
feature comes in.
It is essentially
a custom dictionary
that the API uses to
consistently translate
your domain-specific
terminology.
Here's how it works.
We create a glossary file
with samples of our source
and target language
phrases and save it
in Google Cloud Storage.
Then, we make a
translation request
using the glossary files.
Now, let's apply
this to our example.
We create a glossary file,
name it glossary.csv.
And you can also create
them in TMX or TSV formats,
if you want.
Let's add some examples here.
Google Cloud stays the same,
Translation API stays the same,
while technology translates.
Upload this file
to a GCS bucket.
Before we start
using the glossary,
we need to register it and
create a glossary ID, wherein
the payload, we mention
the source and target
language, along with the
location of the file.
And now, we are
ready to translate
the text using our glossary.
And here we see the translation
now takes our glossary
into account and considers
Google Cloud as a proper noun.
So far, we've seen
text translation
for a single string.
But what if you wanted to
translate multiple files
in multiple languages?
That's where the Batch
Translation feature comes in.
It is easy.
Upload the files you want to
translate into Google Cloud
Storage, request translations
in multiple languages,
and then store the translations
in Google Cloud Storage.
Let's see how this works.
I have this sample text
file that we will translate
in a few different languages.
We define our request body in
the three languages, Spanish,
French, and Hindi.
Provide the path for the source
and destination in Google Cloud
Storage, then make a
call to the API endpoint
with Batch Translate text
using our request body.
Now, let's go to our
Google Cloud Storage bucket
to see our translated files.
And they are available
for us to use.
In this episode, we
learned how Translation API
works, and tried some advanced
features, such as Batch
Translation for batch
translation needs
and Glossary for
correctly translating
proper notes and product names.
I look forward to seeing
you on the next episode
of "AI Adventures,"
where we will
explore custom
domain-specific models using
AutoML translation.
In the meantime, if you
have enjoyed this video,
click that Like button,
and be sure to subscribe
to get notified about the latest
episodes right when they come.